bonsoir roger karoutchi merci d'être
avec nous en direct de la défense vous
voyez faire les gros yeux
voilà son rire sans doute ironiquement à
ces propos votre réaction circulez ya
rien à voir
à du côté du gouvernement c'est clair
qu'on ne souhaite pas être très
contrôlés sur sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
on sait depuis le début depuis les
errements sur les masques puis sur les
thèses puis dans la campagne vaccinale
le gouvernement n'a pas vraiment envie
que les parlementaires contrôle en
réalité sa gestion de la crise alors au
nom de l'unité nationale on voudrait
bien faire taire tout le monde alors à
l'assemblée nationale c'est possible
parce que la majorité aux ordres a fait
en sorte que la mission d'information
s'arrête au sénat où il ya déjà eu une
commission d' enquête qui a déposé un
rapport au mois de décembre la mission
d'information s'est mise en place cette
semaine
elle aura ses premières réunions dans
les semaines qui viennent jusqu'à l'été
j'en serais d'ailleurs rapporteur et je
n'ai pas l'intention d'obéir à une
quelconque diktat de qui que ce soit
nous allons faire notre travail de
parlementaire vérifier ce qui se fait
s'il ya des choses bien
faut pas que le gouvernement ici peur
que ça doit bien faire de temps en temps
des choses correctes
donc on dira que c'est bien s'il ya des
choses qui ne nous paraissent pas
correct mais on le dira auditionné et je
pense que les ministres n'auront guère
le choix à parvenir être auditionné par
le sénat s'ils veulent pas être
auditionné par l'assemblée mais
globalement je trouve que un moment où
on voit bien que l'épidémie est loin
d'être terminée
on voit bien au moment où la campagne
vaccinale parti et où il ya des
problèmes européens et français
on voit bien que si le gouvernement veut
un peu l'unité d'une opinion arriver à
peu près à faire retrouver la confiance
il faut qu'il accepte le dialogue il
faut qu'ils acceptent de parler faut
qu'il accepte d'être contrôlé il faut
qu'il accepte que les parlementaires
pose des questions parce que dans le
fond les questions que nous posons sont
les questions que posent tous les
français qu'ils se pose pas est-ce qu'on
va être confiné une troisième fois
est-ce que ça suffira est ce que ne n'y
aura pas assez de vaccins passée de
vaccination 10 hier et mais est-ce qu'on
ne risque pas encore une quatrième un
quatrième confinement en avril ou en mai
tom qu'on ne sera pas arrivé à vacciner
suffisamment demande toutes ces
questions tous les français se les
posent
même s'ils sont dans la majorité
politique de monsieur maquereau thon
qu'autant qui en débat au parlement
avec un rapport avec des échanges aux 46
66 millions de procureur nous reproche
un petit peu emmanuel macron quand même
qui plaide le droit à l'erreur
vous le sentez un petit peu embarrassé
justement par ces critiques le président
de la république
si on en croit certaines réactions qu'il
ait vue y compris par rapport à ses
ministres par rapport à certain retard
je pense qu'il est assez embarrassé qui
se rend compte que cette crise sanitaire
est plus dur que le gouvernement ne le
prévoyaient que d'ailleurs la majorité
des experts ne prévoient il faut pas non
plus jeter de pierres uniquement là
dessus mais ce qui est clair c'est que
le gouvernement ne passera pas et le
prix hommage unique ne passera pas
l'ensemble de cette crise sanitaire qui
va encore durer des mois sans avoir à
s'expliquer et c'est normal c'est le
gouvernement qui par définition elle
pouvoir exécutif c'est lui qui prend les
décisions
il faut bien qu'il en rende compte c'est
ça le principal problème en supprimant
la mission d'information à l'assemblée
dans le sentiment que le gouvernement
voudrait pouvoir prendre des décisions
sans en rendre compte
mais ça ça n'existe pas nous sommes dans
une démocratie en république
le gouvernement n'est pas tout puissant
le président non plus il ad est il à
rendre des explications sur ce qu'il
fait sur ce que le gouvernement fait et
c'est normal c'est la vie des pratiques
les députés le 10 mai en fait ce travail
était tout simplement terminer cette
mission est terminée ils ne disent pas
qu'il ne voulait pas répondre aux
questions il estime tout simplement
qu'ils y ont répondu mais voilà qu'ils
ont donné les réponses est ce que pour
vous est ce que cette mission était
réellement terminée ce qu'il ya encore
des questions auxquelles vous n'avez pas
de réponse aujourd'hui je me permettrai
de vous répondre simplement par une
autre question est ce que la crise
sanitaire est terminée est-ce que nous
sommes sortis de la crise sanitaire on
voit bien nous avons au sénat comme à
l'assemblée fait les rapports des
commissions d'amm quête début des saints
donc on était encore loin des débuts de
la campagne vaccinale
on n'imaginait pas un troisième le
confinement on n'imaginait pas que la
crise économique sociale sociétale
allait être encore plus profonde et
devoir durer des mois
par conséquent très logiquement au sénat
on a dit la commission denquête a déposé
son rapport en décembre mais la crise
sanitaire et ses conséquences se
poursuivre
il est normal que le parlement puisse
avoir des explications des échanges et
qu'il y ait une mission d'information
il s'agit pas de créer des missions pour
condamner et uniquement critiquer on
cherche à avoir des explications à
contrôler l'action qui est menée et
pardon mais le rôle du parlement c'est
le contrôler l'action du gouvernement
c'est dans la constitution
et je m'étonne qu'à l'assemblée on se
dessaisisse de ce pouvoir parce que ça
ne correspond pas du tout à l'esprit de
la vème république
on entendait pascal canfin l'autre jour
se plaindre de ne pas pouvoir obtenir
les contrats passés entre la commission
européenne et les laboratoires qui
fabriquent les vaccins ce que c'est un
axe par exemple sur lequel vous allez
vous essayer travailler les sénateurs
pour avoir plus de transparence sur ces
commandes qui interroge beaucoup il faut
bien le dire
alors forcément nous on va beaucoup
s'intéresser à la vie franco-français si
je puis dire par rapport à la crise
mais c'est vrai que dans les
explications dans les discussions qui
auront lieu
c'est sûr que les ratés de la campagne
vaccinale qui ne sont pas que du fait de
l'état français mais qui sont aussi du
fait peut-être deux
d'erreurs dans les liens entre l'union
européenne et les laboratoires
interrogé le comportement des
laboratoires parce que pourquoi et
avait-il pris des engagements pourquoi
ces engagements ne sont pas tenus ou en
tout cas seulement partiellement
forcément c'est une question qui va se
poser et qui va se poser d'ailleurs au
delà de la mission d'information parce
que pardon mais même si l assemblée
nationale il ya plus de missions
d'information là dessus vous pensez aux
questions d'actualité
ces questions là les groupes
d'opposition vont pas déposer
naturellement que oui c'est pour ça que
je trouve assez ridicule de refuser de
maintenir la mission d'information à
l'assemblée parce que de toute manière
les questions vont être posées
de toute manière le gouvernement devra
s'expliquer et par conséquent il eût
mieux valu que ce soit dans un travail
coordonné concerter avec des missions
vraiment fait pour ça ce qu'on veut
faire aussi sans esprit de polémique
pour la polémique même si le sénat à une
majorité de droite et du centre on sait
ce qu est l unité nationale on sait ce
qu'est la nécessité de trouver des
solutions pour nos concitoyens
donc on va faire ça dans un esprit
constructif mais en voulant des
explications en voulant qu'on nous dise
clairement les choses de la transparence
c'est tout gouvernement qui en période
de crise joue la transparence n'y perd
pas voilà c'est la seule chose que je
peux dire un au 1er mai disent
franchement être trouvé la parade pour
éviter quelques critiques puisqu'il va
vous associez les parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat la
semaine prochaine puisque vous allez
être invités à voter
il y aura un débat et un vote après les
nouvelles mesures qu'on attend tous avec
beaucoup d'impatience
c'est une manière peut-être aussi vous
responsabiliser de ne plus endosser
toutes les responsabilités de ce genre
de moore de décision alors pardon mais
il ya des subtilités dans la
constitution
et de ce côté là par exemple on nous dit
que nos réalités pas par exemple au
sénat mardi très bien sauf que
apparemment j'en sais rien
faut que ça on nous dit que le président
la république pourrait s'exprimer dès
dimanche ou lundi
c'est à dire qu'en réalité on va nous
faire débattre une fois les décisions
annoncées par le président de la
république à l'ensemble des français
donc franchement histoire de dire qu'on
fait quelque chose au parlement deuxième
élément pardon c'est une subtilité mais
le débat aura lieu en fonction de
l'article 50-1 de la constitution et le
vote qui suit n'est qu'indicatif c'est à
dire qu'en fait l'assemblée où le sénat
nication votre site c'est en réalité un
débat indicatif seul sera d'autant plus
si le président de la république
s'exprime avant pour donner les vraies
décisions parce que ça voudrait dire
enfin des bas mais sur les annonces
faites par le président et non pas sur
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
ce qu'on demande d'ailleurs depuis des
mois et des mois où on demande
régulièrement au gouvernement mais
pourquoi ne n'arrive-t-on pas avoir un
débat parlementaire sur des solutions ou
des propositions par rapport à la crise
l'opposition d'être dans l'opposition ça
ne rend pas aveugle aux difficultés au
tram de beaucoup de français
tout le monde souhaite sortir de la
crise sanitaire et donc après tout on
peut avoir des idées je vois pas en quoi
ce serait aberrant qui est un vrai des
partenaires en l'occurrence ce sera un
débat post décision présidentielle et
qui ne sera qu indicatif
merci beaucoup roger karoutchi je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur des
hauts-de-seine merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france